i can't do that anymore that dance oh
really oh
yeah that's done it's done had to end
somehow
yeah it had to end yeah because i mean
it's an amazing closure
it was the only is the only closer that
every
weight staff and every comedian would
still pile into the room to see even
though you've seen it it's it's
yeah i would uh defeat i remember one
time like maybe a couple years ago
um i have a christian friend her name is
beverly and she lives in texas and she
had never seen the strip tase
and she saw the show she was laughing
through the whole show but then when she
saw it
her husband and herself came up to me
after the show
they came in the green room they throw
holy water at you no and they
were really concerned what yeah i just
think
for your well-being no like i don't
think that you need to do that i think
it's
against you know because i know you
don't believe in christ
but um it's against the energies
of of what christ would want you to do
it's just
it's it's blasphemy you know me and i'd
be like
i was like but it's killing
yeah i don't care about christ the
audience loves it
christ's also killed too yeah but like
and then i remember being in kansas city
and the
manager doing that dance and the manager
being a christian
he he told me to come into his office
and he
said let's pray about it really yeah so
we got on our hands and knees and we
prayed about it oh i love that offer
i love when people ask to pray over
things that i've yeah
but then i did it every show after that
that's what my grandma does
when i call her like she'll like check
in on me and stuff like that she's like
well let's let's just pray about it pray
on this let's just pray on this
no is your grandmother do they because i
know that you come from a religious
family
are they freaked out that you're still
out here my grandma is for sure
and why yeah what do you mean why i mean
she thinks this is the
the double satan city you know what i
mean she does yeah she's like what's up
the only time
about it the only time she was proud of
me is when i did a chevy volt commercial
really she saw it on cnn and fox and she
could show her friends and the old folks
home yeah she's like
she literally said to me she goes well
uh i don't agree with a lot of that you
do out there but if you keep working for
good american companies like
chevy then i can get behind that like
what you know it's it's the divisions
because you know it's it's funny you and
i both jeremiah
have been out in the world we've got
we've been in red states yeah
performed and the people that come out
look like the people that you would see
in la
right you don't really see a difference
i don't and it's like it's funny how
people think that like la's some sort of
like
wasteland or you know some dystopian
wasteland where it's like
there's crime happening no you see kids
you know i mean in families and
like you would see anywhere else it's
all the same and yet
you know i don't know it's it's it's
just weird out there man
it's you know i think maybe the media
does have something to do with it
yeah they think they have a lot to do
with it right
carving out some sort of like you know
it's all about perception or
narratives narrative thank you about
narratives you know
but we're all the same i want to meet
your grandma will she meet me
i don't think so
[Laughter]
why i mean would she say the g word
no no no but okay let's you play your
grandmother has she seen an asian you
you you play your grandmother i come
over
okay where does she live in an apartment
she lives in like an old folks home
right now all right so what room number
is it
well well it's not going that out it's
two two
hello hi what's your name what's her
name bernice
bernice hey what's up my name is bobby
i'm okay i'm one of the new nurses
no no no no no no no
i'm jeremiah's friend from los angeles
i'm a comic he opens for me sometimes
oh how's he doing i don't hear from him
he's
doing great he's really climbing the
comedy ladder and
i think he's very talented can i come in
uh okay all right so bernice
bernice yes bernice yeah yeah
um how do you feel about jeremiah being
in l.a
ah i feel like he's a lost soul
you oh i feel like if if he gets right
with god and maybe comes back to kansas
and
finds a different career path and that
would be
more in god's storyline for him wow
yeah right so you think that like you
know
because bernie is if like van gogh right
didn't paint
would you think that that would have
been a good thing
i think you're comparing apples and
oranges bobby
what do you mean there's one true god
and there's only one path to him
bye
i would not know what to say oh yeah you
don't know yeah yeah bye
there's no it's you hit a railroad she's
really like
hand made his tail i mean it's pretty
she was a a missionary
in the cayman islands uh like so she has
taught like with
like she they were like the only white
people on the cayman islands
oh they were like taken care of like
they like
there and it was very like a unique
situation where like they were very
revered and very respected because
they were you know they're rare people
who were bringing god's message to them
yeah so it's a whole different so if i
said to
betrays bernie's bernice riot batrese
bernice if i said your grandmother
bernice i said um
jeremiah and i are getting married what
would she do i
you wanted me to no no that's jeremiah
okay i didn't know if you wanted me to
stay
what would she do i mean she would she
i think that she would tell you to your
face like i don't believe that
gays should get married and i think that
you can pray about this and get rid of
this
wow that's it you know what i mean you
can't change that you can't yeah
yeah there's not like i'm not it's not a
hap i'm happy for you kind of thing like
she wouldn't think one way she wouldn't
come see you perform that i would never
invite her
she would have a heart attack if she if
she had if she found my youtube
if she ever saw my youtube my family's
been hiding my youtube from her
for so many years because she's not that
tech savvy but
she could get like she could get on the
internet if she wants to yeah
and i think that she kind of knows by
the way my family
talks about stuff like like i don't know
it's kind of like a family who their
daughter does porn and they're like no
she's you know she's still she's doing
some modeling
and stuff like that it's it's you don't
need to see it like
we'll let you know when it comes out
when the next project comes out but
your parents aren't like that no they
used to be at some point like more
more so my dad but yeah but your dad is
into it now
because because well because what you
posted on instagram
oh i know was a newspaper article yeah
that a newspaper that
you and your dad as when you were a kid
used to read every sunday right
and now you're in the arts and leisures
portion of the
now did grandma bernice see that i hope
that they take it to her
i mean that would that would probably be
nice because they talk about and they
talk about in the article how i
the guy who watched my special uh how i
don't uh i don't swear in it like i talk
about graphic stuff but i don't swear
and my grandma probably loved that
you know yeah yeah so he called my
comedy pg19 because that's what i do i
don't really swear
with my stand-up i choose to be to paint
the
the words differently with different
stuff just because i've like never had
like people it's weird people come up to
me like after shows after i'm talking
about [ __ ] and stuff
and they're like thank you so much for
not swearing tonight
yeah yeah they don't